next we've got the latest iconic film to
get a new life on tv this is so exciting
deadline reports paramount plus has just
started shooting its greece prequel
series yes greece is the word it's
called greece rise of the pink ladies
cute and the cast has just been
announced with a bunch of new young
talent uh marissa davila cheyenne isabel
wells and tricia fukuhara and it's set
in 1954 which is like four years before
the movie and it promises electrifying
dance numbers choreographed by my friend
jamal sims who choreographs on rupaul's
drag race that's right
and and jamal's choreography is is
unmatched and then the music is done by
another friend of mine justin tranter
who's a grammy-winning producer who's
worked with gaga dua lipa justin bieber
everybody
they've got the best of the best and all
i ask is can i please get a pink lady
jacket because that's all i ever wanted
please
all right next up well and good just ask
relationship experts one big question
and i want your opinion drew should your
partner be your best friend well their
answer they say it depends on what you
mean by best friend if you mean one of a
number of good friends in your life then
yeah it is vital to be friends with the
person you love however if they mean
your best friend as in like the best
friend above all others the only person
that fills that role it may be not so
good
and i agree i think your partner should
be one of your best friends because you
need someone who you can
talk about your partner to when your
partner is being annoying right and you
can't really do that
i'm that for you although i'm more i'm
your flower girl but i'm also like yeah
she is you have a life outside of
wellington i think is what you're
what i'm getting absolutely i think and
i think it it can happen that way when
you get in a relationship you can become
very insulated from the outside world
and i think it's important to have
really good friends a group of people
you know that you can go to and talk to
because it's almost like a pressure
release from your relationship when you
need it at this point in my life if
if someone said you are my everything i
would run as fast as possible
i don't want to be able to use
everything i don't think someone should
be your everything i don't call my kids
friends like i always say i'm not your
friend i'm your mom yeah um although
they are my favorite people to hang out
with
but like
you shouldn't be friends with your kids
and i feel weirdly the same way
as like your lover and partner like you
have to have things that you go outside
to bring back in to keep the
relationship energized and fresh and
full of outside content when you just
start like
life forcing off of someone i think it
gets draining and sort of the opposite
effect totally and i think you become
less of an interesting person when you
put all your eggs in one basket my
favorite part of the day is when willie
and i go out we have our lives and then
we come home and debrief about the day
100 it's too much pressure you're
putting way too much onus on that person
then they can take it and giveth and
that scares me like spread yourself
around
um as far as
outside forces that fill you as well as
figuring out how to fill yourself but i
did not know these things when i was
younger i was like
oh i love you i'm gonna die without you
that was me in my teens and twenties
thirties was like all right i'm gonna
settle down and figure this out in my
40s and like
make spread it spread it spread it
around
[Music]